bonsoir félix moati dans télé gaucho
remercier ma mère toute cette équipe
sans laquelle ce film on finit jamais pu
se faire je voudrais que vous sachiez
que un petit gars comme moi qui viens de
bures sur yvette
c'est un honneur ce soir kc mottet klein
logements dans le pays
j'ai bien fait mon jeu serait créé votre
excuse mais c'est pas vrai t'as
le bateau pirate démodé pierre niney non
comme des frères tous pirates ferai
jamais joué avec talent le bateau pirate
playmobil en entier est à la maison avec
ouais bah ouais et baffes qui se perdent
est ce que tu sais combien d'enfants
raté avoir sali sas pour moi c'est comme
à par scarlett johansson dans son lit à
les piocher dans la baignoire sait enfin
où mireille darc matthias schoenaerts
c'est pas pour le pognon pour toi tu
fais je n'ai jamais dit que c'était pas
prononcé tiens au fait pourquoi je fais
pour mes bottes pour le fun c'est comme
toi sur des poissons tu sais pourquoi tu
sais pour le fun et intitulé world ans
dans la maison depuis un an je rêvais de
rentrer dans cette poésie
j'ai réussi à me en produire à observer
la famille normale de très près j'ai
même cru pouvoir devenir l'un des leurs
et le césar est attribué à matthias
schoenaerts qui joue un père cochet 2000
s'installe avec senti chez sa soeur
antilles dont il va tomber amoureux une
dresseuse d'orques en superpole
c'est le premier comédien belge à
remporter ce prix aux dires voulait au
départ qu'on avait fait en aux
professionnels et son directeur de
casting richard rousseau lui a montré le
film blade qui est nommé ce soir et
c'est là que jacques audiard a choisi
matthias schoenaerts deuxième césar pour
de rouille et d'os ce soir
à
merci beaucoup je me rends compte que le
champagne il est assez puissant la voilà
je suis je suis énormément touchée
d'être accueilli de cette façon dans la
famille française sais pas quoi dire
d'abord il faut que je remercie jacques
jacques audiard qui qui m'a emmené dans
cette histoire d'amour tellement
puissante et inoubliable j'espère qu'il
y en aura d'autres
avec lui j'ai connu trois génies dans ma
vie j'ai un corner 1
après il faut il faut que je il faut que
je remercie des gens qui me sont proches
aussi dans ma famille ma mère une femme
incroyable sans elle je serais pas ici
ma copine la ravissante alexandra et
après j'aimerais bien dédier ce prix à
tous les comédiens qui n'ont jamais eu
qui n'ont jamais gagné en prime et qui
qui en mérite et 1
il y en a beaucoup dommage mais c'est
comme ça voila j'aimerais bien dédier ce
prix aussi à mon père qui est décédé
depuis longtemps
j'aimerais le sidérant mer j'aimerais le
site et en même temps s'il n'y a pas de
mots s'il n'y a pas d'amour il n'y a
rien et fall a finalement j'aimerais
dédier ce prix à marianne assez vite
chez un ami à moi qui voilà qui se
trouvent dans des situations assez
pénible et je pense à lui et merci
beaucoup
voilà